[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
واحييكم واقدم اليكم العربيه 360 حيث
الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
وسط ترحيب سعودي وامريكي طرف النزاع في
السودان يوقعان في جده على اتفاق لتمديد
الهدنه لخمسه ايام
روسيا تشعل سماء اكياس بالصواريخ والدفاع
الاوكرانيه تؤكد انه هجومها المضاد بدا
بسلسله عمليات
وزير الداخليه اللبناني يؤكد للعربيه ان
المواطن السعودي المختطف بخير ويتوعد
بمحاسبه المنفذين
ولدينا ايضا
اردوغان يواجهون قسامات حاده في اول ايام
ولايته الجديده وتحديات اقتصاديه ابرزها
تدحرج الليره
[موسيقى]
البدايه من اخر التطورات في السودان فقد
افادت مراسله العربيه بتوقيع وفدي الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في جده
اتفاقا لتمديد الهدنه مده خمسه ايام اخرى
هذا ورحبت السعوديه والولايات المتحده
بتمديد الهدنه وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه
في بيان ان تمديدها سيتيح الفرصه لمناقشه
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار لمده اطول زمنيا
معنى من جده الان مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان لما يعقوب اهلا بك معنا لينا اي
معلومات تفصيليه اخرى لدينا فيما يتعلق
بهذا التمديد
مساء الخير عليك طاهر هذا التمديد تم كما
هو منصوص عليه في الاتفاق الشروط التي كان
وضعها الطرفين سواء الجيش او الدعم السريع
باقناع من الوساطه اجلت لنقاش بعد توقيع
تمديد هذه الهدنه التي تستمر هذه المره
لخمسه ايام كما تعلم كانت هناك هدنه في
الحادي عشر من مايو وهدنه في العشرين من
مايو والان هذا هو التمديد الثالث وسنتابع
في الحديث عن هذه الهدنه معك لينا ولكن
بعد يعني ان يتم اصلاح
يعني الخلل في الصوت الذين تلقاه منك بسبب
خلل فني شكرا جزيلا لك للان نعود اليك بعد
قليل اضحى ظهور سلاح باقليم دارفور
السوداني بعد القتال بين الجيش والدعم
مظهرا شبهه عادي على الرغم من منعه في
السابق ويتخوف سكان الاقليم من الدعوات
المتكرره للتسلح من جهات النافذه بان
تفاقم بان تفاقم من حاله السيوله الامنيه
الحاليه بداف ور
يتجول سليمان حسب الكريم بسلاحه داخل سوق
الضعين غربيه السودان في مشهد اصبح مالوفا
في مدن اقليم دارفور فمنذ اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منتصف ابريل
الماضي عاد السلاح مره اخرى الى الزهور
بكثره في ايدي المواطنين بالاحياء
والاسواق حجتهم في ذلك حمايه انفسهم من
النهب والسلب والله لحمايه نفسي بس وانا
زلت تاجر وقاعد في الخلا وشايل السلاح
لعدم حفظ الامن لانه ما في اسي دوله
تحمانا
من النهب والسلب عشان كده انا شايل السلاح
وعشر دارفور في السنوات السابقه صراعات
عديده متواصله استخدم فيها السلاح بشكل
سافر مما جعل بعض القيادات الاهليه تتخوف
من تكرار ذات الخلافات القديمه التي عاشها
الاقليم بسبب السلاح والسيوله الامنيه
لذلك نحن نقول هذه الخطوه خطوه غير موفقه
ونحن نطالب المجتمع الدولي والاخوه
والسطاع السعوديين والمتحده ان يقفوا على
هذه الحاله لان هذه الازمه ستصبح ازمه
يمكنكم تضييق على السودانيين فيما ينادي
بعض المواطنين بالمضي قدما في عمليات جمع
السلاح بدلا من تقنين انتشاره خوفا من
الانزلاق الى الحرب الاهليه بدرفور مشيرين
الى ان بعض المناطق ما زالت ساخنه نحن
نرفض جمله وتفصيلا لان الاستمرار السلاح
عند المواطن ذات نجمع نحن الان نحن مع جهه
وتجمع السلاح جمع السلاح ومحاربه الظواهر
السالمه نحن الان ما دارين سرقات
كل الحاجات دي احنا الان محاربينها تماما
وما دايرين اي خلل وتقول جهات مختصه انه
رغم الحملات المتكرره فلا يزال السلاح
بكافه انواعه بحوزه سكان دارفور انقسام
للمجتمع بيدارفور بين مؤيد ورافض التسليح
بغرض الحمايه وبين مجموعه الرفض وتاييد
قاسم مشترك وحمايه الارواح والممتلكات
وتعزيز الامن والسلام
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
ونعود الى موضوع تمديد الهدنه في السودان
لخمسه ايام من جده معنا مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان لينا يعقوب اهلا بك
معنا مجددا لينا اذا كنت تتحدثين عما
لدينا من معلومات اضافيه عن هذا التمديد
وكيف يمكن له ان يسمح كما قالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه باتفاق اطول زمنيه
نعم طاهر كما ذكرت لك ان الجيش كان لديه
اشتراطات لتمديد هذه الهدنه وكذلك الدعم
السريع ولكن باقناع من الوساطه تم تاجيل
النقاشات خلال الايام المقبله او خلال
الخمسه ايام المقبله بعد تمديد الهدنه
وهذا هو التمديد الثالث كانت هناك هدنه في
الحادي عشر من مايو وهدنا في العشرين من
مايو استمرت اسبوع والان هذه هي لهدنه
الثالثه تستمر لمده خمسه ايام في خلال
الخمسه ايام ستكون هناك نقاشات مباشره حول
الخروقات التي تمت في هذه الهدنه من كلا
الطرفين من الجيش والدعم السريع الدعم
السريع يتحدث ان هناك تحليق للطائرات
والمسيرات وهناك قصف بالطائرات لبعض
المواقع التي تتبع له وكما يقول هناك قص
تضرر منه مدنيين على الصعيد الاخر الجيش
يتحدث بصوره مباشره على استمرار الخروقات
سواء كان باطلاق اسلحه خفيفه او ثقيله
استمرار احتلال المنازل ومساكن المواطنين
المرافق العامه خاصه وكذلك طبعا بلا شك
استمرار عمليات النهب والسلب من قبل الدعم
السريع وبعض العصابات الاجراميه بيان
الوساطه اشارلي هذه الامور بصوره واضحه
لذلك تمديد هذه الهدنه خاصه ان الوساطه
تؤكد بان هناك مساعدات انسانيه ادخلت الى
بعض المستشفيات التي تعمل صحيح ان البعض
يتحدث عن اعتراض لبعض عمال الاغاثه ولكن
اللجنه العليا لمتابعه الاوضاع الانسانيه
في السودان اكدت بانها ستعمل على تنفيذ
هذا الاتفاق وعلى اعطاء تاشيرات لكل عمال
الاغاثه وتوفير سبل الحمايه الممكنه لهم
لذلك هذا الاتفاق بحسب الاطراف المختلفه
يمهد الاستمرار ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
على قلتها وانه ايضا يسهم بصوره مباشره في
تقليل الاشتباكات التي راح ضحيتها مئات
المواطنين في الفتره الاولى من هذه الحرب
الهدنه بصوره مباشره حتى ان لم تكن مقنعه
للمواطنين لان السريع ما زال يحتل بيوت
المواطنين ولكنها ايضا تعتبر نوع اخف من
حيث الاشتباكات مقارنه بالايام الاولى
والاسابيع الاولى من الحرب ومقارنه مقارنه
بهذا الاسبوع الذي منك الى ماذا يمكن ان
يستمر الوضع على حاله والى اي مدى يمكن
لهذه الدول الراعيه ان تقبل بمجرد التمديد
في كل مره اذا انتهت الخمسه ايام هذه يعني
عنده انقضائها ما الذي سيحصل ولكن نشير
الى الاخبار العاجله على الشاشه عن
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
التي كانت قبل قليل الذي يدعو الى
الالتزام الصارم بنصوص وقت اطلاق النار
وتركيز الجهود على معالجه الوضع الانساني
المتدهور ويرحب باتفاق الجيش والدعم
السريع على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار خمسه
ايام ولكن لينا سؤال الان هل سنبقى يعني
هكذا خمسه ايام بعد خمسه ايام الى يعني ما
شاء الله او ماذا نقطه الفصل او الوصل مع
وقف كامل لاطلاق النا ر ما الذي ينتظر
ليتم الاتفاق عليه حتى نصل الى هذا المصاف
طاهر هذا السؤال كل السودانيين هذا السؤال
انت تطرحه على لسان الجميع ماذا بعد تمديد
الخمسه ايام خاصه ان البعض كان يعتقد بان
ما قالته الوساطه بصوره واضحه في البيان
باستمرار عمليات احتلال المرافق العامه
والخاصه ومنازل المواطنين واستمرار عمليات
النهب والسلب من قوات الدعم السريع وعلى
صعيد الاخر ايضا استمرار الاشتباكات من
جانب الجيش والدعم السريع في بعض المناطق
يطرح سؤال مهم بالنسبه للمواطنين ماذا ان
استمرت هذه الخمسه ايام بلا تنفيذ
الاتفاق والذي ان نفذ بصورته الكامله
سيقنع الكثيرين لذلك الوساطه تعتقد رغم
الفروقات التي تمت من كلا الطرفين الا ان
الفرصه مواتيه لمنع ربما
او لتقليل فرص هذا الاختراق لمحاوله تفعيل
اليات جديده ووضع اليه رقابه جديده
يعني افضل من وضع هذا الاتصال على الاقل
معك عدنا الى خلل كبير في الصوت يجب ان
نتركك هنا ولكن شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات لنقل يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه
في السودان من جده تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا ملاجئ اطفال السودان
تتحول لمقابر وفاه 50 طفلا بينهم عشرون
رضيعا بدار ايتام في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد امام هول الصوره لا يوجد
تفسير ولا تبرير وامام الماساه لا مكان
للمواساه اطفال يولدون في السودان مشتعل
ويرحلون قبل ان تنطفئ النيران قصه مؤلمه
لا مكان فيها للحياه من دار رعايه للاطفال
اين في الخرطوم
تهدئه روع السودانيين لا في الشوارع التي
تعج بالمسلحين ولا حتى في ملاجئ الاطفال
حيث لا امان يطوقهم
الان الوضع بيقى صعب جدا جدا اسره خاليه
من اجسادهم الغضه يتمتهم والحياه مرتين
فقد السند ثم عرف الموت طريقه الى دار
المايكوما للايتام في الخرطوم اكثر من
خمسين طفلا بينهم عشرون رضيعا سلبتهم
الحرب حياتهم جوعا ووهنا وخلال 24 ساعه
فقدت حياته 13 اخرين لم تتجاوز اعمارهم
ربيعا واحدا ربيعا ما كان كافيا ليقف على
ارجلهم ذاهبين الى مكانهم المفضل بين
الاراجيح
[موسيقى]
بكوا لساعات حان وقت رضعتهم لكن لحليب
يقطر في افواههم كل المنجدين عاثت بهم طرق
لا صوت يعلو فيها سوى عزيزي الرصاص فكانت
دمار اقسى من ان يؤمن لهم الغذاء وادنى
حقوق الرعايه الصحيه
هذه دعوه لمساعده انسانيه وسلام وامل
بحياه طبيعيه وافضل للايتام المحاصرين في
الخرطوم بسبب الحرب والانتهاكات انا اقفه
هنا في هذا الوضع للمره الثانيه ارجوكم
هناك ما يفوق الثلاثه مئه طفل تتراوح
اعمارهم بين ايام وسنوات ينتظرون نجدتكم
يهدا القصف فيهرع الاطباء الى تلك الدور
لتكون الصدمه مشاهد اقسى من الوصف رضع
وخدج اتوا الى الدنيا لايام وفارقوها
باكفان لفتهم قبل ان يكتبوا حلما كان قد
مر في خيالهم اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الامنيه للبلد عمل التربي في
طلعت من الخدمه ونحن في منطقه هي في مرمى
النيران
كلها يعني غيار جروح عنده علاج عنده متوفر
في البيت او زايد يوديه لناس الطوارئ احنا
هنا في الراشدين شمال
بنحتاج لكل الادويه بنحتاج للاطباء
محتاجين لاي زوجاته انه يساعدنا
[موسيقى]
ونتابع من تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا فقد
اطلقت روسيا عشرات صواريخ والمسيرات على
العاصمه كييف السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت
التصدي للهجمات فيما ظهرت مقاطع متداوله
اعتراض دفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
صواريخاروسيه في سماء كييف
[موسيقى]
الجيش الروسي اعلن استهداف مراكز قياده
ومعدات طيران ومخازن اسلحه وذخيره
اوكرانيه بضربات جويه على المطارات
الاوكرانيه خلال الليل واشار المتحدث باسم
الدفاع الروسيه اجورا ان ضربات كانت
باسلحه بعيده المدى وموجهه بدقه وحققت
اهدافها
[موسيقى]
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه الليله
الماضيه ضربه جماعيه باسلحه جويه بعيده
المدى موجهه بدقه ضد اهداف معاديه في
المطارات الاوكرانيه تم تحقيق هدف الضربه
الجويه وتدمير كل الاهداف نتيجه الضربه تم
تدمير مراكز القياده ومراكز الرادار وكذلك
معدات الطيران ومرافق تخزين اسلحه وذخائر
تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
معنى من اهلنا عضو البرلمان الاوكراني
اهلا بك معنا استاذه هلنا هذا التصعيد
الجديد كيف يمكن ان نفهمه من الجانب
الروسي ضد اوكرانيا وهل يمكن ان نقول فعلا
بان الهجوم المضاده بدا اوكرانيا من
الاتجاه الاوكراني ضد روسيا بعمليات في
العمق الروسي
هو ان روسيا تخشى الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
الذي يعني تحرير اراضينا وتحرير شعبنا
واطفالنا لكن روسيا تخشى هذا الهجوم
المضاد لذلك في تسعه
لتوجيه ضربات الى اوكرانيا لمنع الهجوم
المضاد من الحصول وهذه
الهجمات ضد اوكرانيا تتم ليلا اثناء النوم
المواطنين يجب ان ندرك ايضا ان الصواريخ
التي تستخدمها روسيا هي غير دقيقه بعضها
قديم جدا وهي لا تصيب اهدافها في الكثير
من الحالات ولكن هي احيانا تطال مباني
سكنيه يناموا فيها المواطنون في الليل
والليله الماضيه على سبيل المثال كان هناك
كاسح ضد اوكرانيا غالبيه الطائرات المسيره
الصواريخ تم اعتراضها من قبل الدفاعات
الجويه ولكن بعضها للاسف
وصلت ليس اهدافها وانما ضربت مباني سكنيه
في مدينه على سبيل المثال ويتقع في شرق
اوكرانيا
الصواريخ
الروسيه قتلت امراه حامل وثلاثه اطفال
وعجوزين اليوم فقط هذه هي الاهداف
الحقيقيه لهذه الهجمات الروسيه التي
تسعى روسيا من خلالها لترويع الشعب
الحوامل والاطفال
وكذلك تستهدف المدارس
وتدفع المواطنين للهروب والبحث عن ملاجئ
هذا ما تقوم به روسيا بالاساس وهذا السلوك
هو سلوك امبرياليه
وهو ترويع
للمواطنين الامنين الذين لاصله لهم
بالعمليه العسكريه
يعني قد يفهم المشاهد طبيعه العمليات
المضاده في هكذا حروب ولكن نسالك بعد ان
نعود اليك بعد قليل كيف يمكن للمشاهد ان
يفهم الدعوات لمنطقه منزوعه السلاح في
داخل روسيا وهذا ما نعود به اليك بعد قليل
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا اشير الى
الخبر العاجل الوارد عن الرئاسه المصريه
اذا الرئاسه المصريه تقول ان الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي والرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان اتفقا على ترفيع فوري
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه وعلى تبادل السفراء
نتابع اوكرانيا روسيا الان اكد مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يوريساك في تصريحات
للعربيه ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده بل بسلسله من
العمليات الجاريه مشيرا الى ان بعض عمليات
الهجوم جاريه منذ عده اسابيع
اما فيما يخص هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا
غير صحيح لان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده في ساعه معينه
ثم نراها على شاشه التلفزيون هذه الهجمات
المضاده هي سلسله من العمليات الصغيره
والكبيره والبعض منها جاريه منذ عده
اسابيع
قال ميخائيل مستشار رئيس الاوكراني انه
ينبغي انشاء منطقه منزوعه السلاح بعمق
يتراوح بين 100 و120 كيلومترا داخل روسيا
بطول حدودها مع اوكرانيا وذلك في اطار اي
تسويه بعد الحرب بحسب ما كتب في تغريده له
عبر موقع تويتر واضافت ان المنطقه
الحدوديه منزوعه السلاح داخل روسيا يجب ان
تخضع لاشراف دوليه
اذا كيف يمكن فهم مثل هذه الدعوه استاذه
هلنا عضو البرلمان الاوكراني من كييف يعني
المشكله كانت
روسيا بعدم قبول ذلك في اوكرانيا فكيف
يمكن ان نتخيل قبولها بذلك في داخل روسيا
هذا
ربما من ذراعي التي تتدرع بها روسيا لغزو
جيرانها ويجب ان نقول ان
الاوكران ليست هي البلد الاول الذي عانى
من الغزو الروسي في روسيا سادفت جورجيا
ومولدوفا وتسببت بعدم الاستقرار هناك ما
نراه في الواقع هو ان روسيا لا تستطيع حل
مشكلتها الداخليه
فثمت
عدد كبير من الفقراء الروس الذين يعانون
من مشكلات متعدده مثل ادمان على الكحول او
مشكله اخرى وروسيا غير قادره على حل هذه
المشكلات الاجتماعيه داخل روسيا وبالتالي
تريد ان تشتت الانتباه وتهجم بذلك جيرانها
وبالاساس
نحن نرى ان السبيل الوحيد لمنع روسيا من
الاقدام على المزيد من العدوان ضد اي بلد
مجاور هو الحد من قدرتها العسكريه
وامكانيه روسيا على الهجوم بما في ذلك
انشاء منطقه منزوعه السلاح داخل روسيا حتى
لا تستطيع روسيا استخدام المسيرات
والصواريخ لمهاجمه وانا متاكد بان
اوكرانيا سوف تضع هذه الشروط في اي
مفاوضاته سلام بعد تحقيق اوكرانيا للنصر
وفي الوقت الرهن فان الاوكرانيين
يضاعفون جهودهم لتسريع النصر نحن نرى ليس
اوكرانيا فقط ولكن العالم بكامله يا رب ان
الجيش الروسي لم يكن كما كان يدعيه فهذا
الجيش لم يتمكن من السيطره على اي اي مدن
او قرى في اوكرانيا على مدى شهور حتى طيله
عام كامل ولذلك فان النصر النصر الاوكراني
لا مفر منه سوف يتحقق في نهايه المطاف
ونعم ان يتحقق ذلك وهذا ما نعمل من اجله
وبعد ذلك سوف نناقش شروط هذا النصر شروط
المفاوضات السلميه
ومن بين هذه الشروط بطبيعه الحال هو الى
حد ما انشاء منطقه منزوعه السلاح داخل
روسيا هذا لن يضر باوكرانيا وبالتالي دول
اخرى سوف تكون بمراه يعني الاذى الروسي
شكرا جزيلا
الاوكرانيه من كياف تحياتي اليك
ونتابع مما قاله جوزيف الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه يعتقد ان روسيا لن
تكون مستعده لدخول في مفاوضات الا اذا
انتصرت في الحرب باوكرانيا واضاف انه غير
متفائل بشان ما يمكن ان يحدث في هذا
الصراع هذا الصيف مشيرا الى انه لدى روسيا
نيه قاطعه لكسب الحرب ولن تدخل في مفاوضات
بدون هذا الهدف على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
قالت السفاره السعوديه في لبنان انها تلقت
بلاغا من ذوي احد المواطنين الذي فقد
الاتصال به فجرا اليوم واضافت سفاره
السعوديه في بيان انها تتواصل مع سلطات
اللبنانيه لكشف ملابسات اختفاء المواطن
السعودي
وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال وزير الداخليه
اللبناني بسام المولوي ان القوى الامنيه
اللبنانيه تتابع بدقه موضوع المواطن
السعودي المختطف في لبنان مضيفا ان
السعوديه المختطف بخير واكد انه يتم اطلاع
السفير السعودي في لبنان على كل التطورات
بشكل فوري هذا الموضوع تتابعه القوى
الامنيه بكل حرفيه ومهنيه
ويجري التواصل بطبيعه الحال مع السفير
السعودي مع معالي السفير وليد البخاري
لاجل متابعه الموضوع ولاجل اطلاعه على ما
يلزم من تفاصيل وعلى ما
تحصل عليه القوى الامنيه نحن علينا متابعه
الموضوع هذا موضوع لا نقبل به هذا موضوع
يمس بعلاقه لبنان بالدول العربيه الشقيقه
وراسيما بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ان امن
وامان كافه المقيمين على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ولا سيما المواطنين
والمواطنين من من مواطني دول الخليج
العربي ومواطنين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هم اشقاء وان امنهم وامانهم مهم جدا
للبنان ولعلاقته لبنان بهذه الدول الشقيقه
واضاف الوزير ان السلطات الامنيه رصد
التحرك هاتف المواطن السعودي المختطف في
اكثر من منطقه وشددا على سريه التحقيق الى
حين التوصل لكافه ملابسات عمليه الاختطاف
متواعدا بمحاسبه المنفذين المعلومات لديك
او لدى
الاعلام تقول بانه تم رصد
مكالمات او رسائل هاتفيه من اكثر من منطقه
هذا يعني ان
هاتف المواطن السعودي يتنقل بين اكثر من
منطقه في بيروت وهذا يدل على
عمل معين لدى الفاعلين وهذا يستوجب على
القوى الامنيه اللبنانيه ان تكون على قدر
كبير من الحيطه ومن الحذر وان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بدقه بالغه
ينبغي لسلامه التحقيق
ولسريه التحقيق الواجبه للوصول الى نتيجه
ولسلامه المواطن السعودي طبعا وهي الاهم
ان نلتزم بحد معين من سريه التحقيق لجلاء
كافه الملابسات
[موسيقى]
بعد فوز الرئيس التركي رجب تايبردوغان
بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه تساءل مراقبون حول
كيفيه تغلب اردوغان على العراقيل التي
واجهته قبل واثناء الانتخابات المزيد في
سياق هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
على مدار اكثر من عقدين تصدر الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان كل الانتخابات التي شهدتها
تركيا واختتمها بفوزه بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه
فوز فتح باب التساؤل حول كيفيه تغلب
اردوغان على العراقيل التي واجهته على
راسها الاقتصاد والزلزال وتحدي المعسكر
الغربي
داخليا حاول اردوغان جذب اصوات الناخبين
خاصه الشباب رغم ترد الاقتصاد عبر تقديم
وعود بخلق سته ملايين وظيفه وتحقيق معدلات
نمو عاليه واعطاء دفعه كبيره للسياحه
وتوفير انترنت مجاني وهواتف دون ضريبه
وبنصف الثمن
المعارضه عولت على الزلزال لخساره اردوغان
الا ان الاخير استطاع امتصاص غضب الناجين
عبر التحرك على ارض الواقع سريعا ببناء
21,244 وحده سكنيه موزعه على احدى عشره
ولايه منكوبه وتعهدات بوضع اساسات
244 الف وحده سكنيه اخرى بغضون شهرين
اضافه الى منح تقدم للطلاب الذين فقدوا
اقارب جراء زلزال
وفي محاوله لدعم المواطنين الاتراك
بمواجهه الاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه رفع
الرئيس التركي الحد الادنى للاجور ثلاث
مرات خلال سنه ووعد بتوفير غاز طبيعي
للمنازل بالمجان
الرئيس التركي حاول الاستفاده من النزعه
القوميه لمواطنيه عبر تعزيز صورته كقائد
عالمي مؤثر مستغلا جهود بلاده بالوساطه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتسليطه الضوء
على قدرات بلاده الدفاعيه بتوفير اسلحه
وصنع اول سفينه حربيه محليه الى جانب
استغلاله تاثير بلاده في حلف شمال الاطلسي
لعرقله ملف انضمام السويد للحلف عوامل
ساهمت وفق مراقبين في فوز اردوغان بولايه
رئاسيه ثالثه
خمس سنوات جديده في سده الرئاسه التركيه
وتحديات عده امام الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
على الصعيدين الداخلي والخارجي تحديات
ثلاثه هي الابرز وكانت مسيطره على المشهد
الانتخابي وهي الازمه الاقتصاديه قضيه
اللاجئين وعلاقه تركيا مع الغرب الاقتصاد
التركي يمر بمرحله حرجه مع وصول معدل
التضخم رسميا الى نحو اربعه واربعين في
المئه مع تشكيك البعض بان معدل التضخم
اعلى بكثير كما ادت سياسات غير التقليديه
التي دعا اليها اردوغان الى هبوط قيمه
الليره التركيه 80% على مدى خمس سنوات
الماضيه وانهيار ثقه الاتراك في عملتهم
ايضا في الشان الداخلي يبقى تحدي اللاجئين
امام اردوغان مثلا ونتحدث هنا عن ثلاثه
ملايين واربع مئه الف لاجئ سوري اضافه
لمئات الالاف من الافغان والايرانيين
والعراقيين اردوغان تعاهد في خطاب مصر
بضمان مليون لاجئ سوري لبلادهم في غضون
سنوات قليله من خلال مشروع سكني جديد يتم
انشاؤه في شمال سوريا ايضا يعمل اردوغان
على حل الخلافات مع الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد ما يزيد من احتمال حدوث التقارب
ربما يساعد تركيا على تخفيف ازمه اللجوء
خارجيا يدعو اردوغان الى ان تتبنى تركيا
تحالفات متعدده الاطراف كما انه يعرض لعب
دوري الوسيط في الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تركيا اتبعت سياسه منفتحه على الصين
وروسيا على حساب حلفاء انقره الغربيين
التقليديين وعلى سبيل المثال اشترت نظام
الدفاع الجوي الروسي اس 400 كما فتحت في
مرحله ما قبل الانتخابات محطه الطاقه
نوويه روسيه صنع هي الاولى من نوعها في
تركيا غربا لا تشير المعطيات بحسب محللين
الى اي تغير في علاقات تركيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الفتره المقبله كما ان التشنج
سيد الموقف في النيتو هناك خبر جديد
اطلعكم عليه بعد قليل مع عدم موافقه تركيا
على ضم السويد للحلف وهو الامر الذي يشكل
اولويه رئيسيه لواشنطن والغرب بانتظار ما
سيبدر عن اردوغان في ولايته الثالثه نتابع
كل هذه المواضيع من اسطنبول مع الكاتب
والمحلل سياسي طه عودي اوغلو اهلا بك
وابدا معك استاذ طه بي الاخبار التي ترد
عن اتصال بايدن باردوغان ويبدو انه الصفقه
الان مع الولايات المتحده ستكون على اساس
تمت او لا تتم هذا نناقشه لاحقا ولكن على
اساس بيع اف 16 لتركيا مقابل موافقه
الاخيره على انضمام السويد الى
هل هذا واقعي بالنسبه اليك
تحياتي لك في البدايه يا استاذ طاهر
والساده المشاهدين نعم يعني كما تفضلت
وذكرت قبل قليل هناك تحديات صعبه توجه
رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في الولايه
الجديده في مقدمتها ترتيب البيت الداخلي
الوضع الاقتصادي
العلاقه او الحفاظ على علاقه متوازنه ما
بين روسيا والغرب الاتصال الهاتف الذي جرى
قبل قليل ما بين بايدن
هو حاليا يعني في غايه الاهميه لماذا لانه
هناك بعد تقريبا اقل من شهر هناك اجتماع
في الناتو وهذا الاجتماع كما تتذكر كان
تعاويل على ان تقبل السويد في
الناتو ان تكون هناك موافقه تركيه ولكن
اذا حتى هذه اللحظه يبدو ان الاتراك مصرين
على ان تكون هناك صفقه كما اشرت ما بين
انقره واشنطن وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالصفقات
العسكريه اف 16 وايضا مقاتلات
كل هذه الامور هي سوف تتضح تباعا خلال
الايام المقبله خاصه ان الحكومه التركيه
او القياده التركيه الجديده التي يعني
فازت بالامس بدات على الفور هناك تحركات
على الصعيد الداخلي وايضا على الصعيد
الخارجي قبل قليل هناك اخبار تتحدث عن
ترفيع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ما بين انقره
والقاهره والتبادل السفراء ايضا
قبل قليل نقلا عن الرئاسه المصريه ولكن
هذا ان دل على شيء على ما يدل بشكل اساسي
استاذ طه فيما يتعلق
يعني نوايا سياسات اردوغان في رئاسته
الثالثه الابقاء على محاولات تصفير
المشاكل لانه هذا بدا قبيل الانتخابات هل
كان لسبب انتخابي او انه سيبقى طيله
الفتره المقبله لاسباب استراتيجيه
يعني انا بتصور اعتقد الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان خلال المرحله المقبله نعم هو
فاز في الانتخاب الانتخابات الاخيره لكن
هناك يتراجع في شعبيه حزب العداله
والتنميه هناك رسائل وجهات من الشارع
التركي للرئيس اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه اي اخطاء ترتكب في الخارج سوف
تكون تنعكس بشكل كبير على الداخل التركي
وخاصه على الاقتصاد اريد ان اشارك لك هذه
المعلومه ايضا يعني قبل ساعات من الان
كانوا هناك لقاء ما بين الرئيس التركي
ومحمد شمسيه ووزير الاسبق وهو وزير كان من
الوزراء الذين ساهموا في نهضه تركيا هناك
معلومات تتحدث عن احتماليه تسليم حقيبه
الاقتصاد في الحكومه المرتقبه الاعلان
عنها خلال الايام المقبله وهناك معلومات
اتحاد يوم الجمعه القادمه هذا اشارات
واضحه بان تركيا حاليا تحاول ترتيب البيت
الداخلي اما فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
الخارجيه اعتقد هناك في تحديات مهمان
الاول وهو العلاقات التركيه المصريه وكما
ذكرنا قبل قليل هناك سوف تتخذ يعني تحرك
او دفعه جديده خلال ايام القادمه وايضا
موضوع السوري ايضا سوف نرى تطورات سريعه
خلال المرحله القادمه وخاصه فيما يتعلق
باعاده اللاجئين اللاجئين لماذا اعاده
اللاجئين لان تركيا كما ذكر رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بالامس في خطابه في اسطنبول بانهم
سوف يبداون استعداد للانتخابات المحليه
المقرر انعقادها في مارس المقبل يعني هناك
عشره اشهر خلال العشره اشهر يجب ان يتم حل
هذا الملف تماما وذلك يعني التطبيع مع
النظام وايضا يعني تحريك او تفعيل مسار مع
روسيا التي ترعى هذا المسار ما بين انقره
نتابع كل هذه التفاصيل معك ومع بقيه
الصحفيين والمحللين السياسيين من اسطنبول
ومن عموم تركيا شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ طه
عوده اوغلو المحلل والك اتب السياسي من
اسطنبول تحياتي لك
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
نقلت وسائل اعلام رسميه ايرانيه ان المرشد
الايراني علي خامنا هي ابلغ سلطان عمان
الذي يزور طهران ان ايران ترحب بتحسين
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع مصر واعاده
العلاقات الثنائيه ولا مشكله لديها في هذا
الصدد
[موسيقى]
محاولات التقارب المصريه الايرانيه عام
2003 الرئيس المصري حسني مبارك يلتقي
نظيره الايراني محمد خاتمي على هامش قمه
دوليه في جناف عام 2012 زياره الرئيس
المصري محمد مرسي لتهران لحضور فعاليات
قمه دول عدم الانحياز عام 2013 الرئيس
الايراني محمود احمد نجاد في القاهره
لحضور قمه منظمه التعاون الاسلامي عام
2022 الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
يلتقي في بغداد وزير خارجيه ايران حسين
امير عبد الله عام 2023 وزير خارجيه ايران
يشير الى مباحثات للتحقيق التقارب بين
القاهره وطهران عام 2023
برلماني ايراني يؤكد الاتفاق على اعاده
فتح السفارتين في البلدين قريبا
عام 2023 المرشد الايراني يؤكد خلال لقائه
سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق ان بلاده ترحب
باعاده العلاقات مع مصر
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا اسلحه نوويه للدول
الراغبه في الانضمام الى دوله الاتحاد بين
روسيا وبيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حاول سكان صرب في شمال
كوسوفو الاستيلاء على مبانئ حكوميه محليه
دخل ها رؤساء بلديات من اصل الباني
الاسبوع الماضي بمساعده الشرطه وقامت شرطه
كوسوفو وقوه حفظ السلام الدوليه بقياده
النيتو بحمايه مبنى البلديه فيزيبيكان حيث
حاول الصرب في شمال البلاد منع المسؤولين
الالباني المنتخبين مؤخرا من دخول مقرات
البلديه من جهتها دانت الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي حكومه كوسوفو
لاستخدامها الشرطه من اجل دخول مقرات
البلديه
[موسيقى]
تويتر تنسحب من اتفاقيه اوروبيه لمكافحه
المعلومات المضلله والاتحاد يقول ان
المنصه لن تستطيع التهرب من التزاماتها تم
اطلاق الميثاق الخاص بالمعلومات المضلله
في الاتحاد الاوروبي عام 2018 وانضم اليه
ما يقرب من 30 موقعا بما في ذلك متى جوجل
تويتر مايكروسوفت وتيك توك ووفق القانون
الاوسع هو قانون الخدمات الرقميه داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجب على الشبكات
العملاقه مثل تويتر تقييم وتخفيف المخاطر
على الراي العام كما يجب على الشركات
زياده شفافيه فيما يتعلق بالتفاعلات مع
المستخدمين وتبسيط اتفاقيات استخدام
المنصات والمواقع ورغم انسحاب الطائر
الازرق من الاتفاقيه الا ان مفوض السوق
الداخليه للاتحاد الاوروبي تياري براتن
قال انه لن يكون بمقدوره تويتر تمصل من
مسؤولياتها في هذا الاطار المسؤول
الاوروبي اعلن ان 25 من اغسطس المقبل
سيكون موعدا لتنفيذ البنود والالتزامات
التي يتضمنها القانون وان على جميع
الشبكات والمنصات مقدمه الخدمات الرقميه
في المنطقه الاوروبيه الالتزام بها بمقتضى
القانون لكن ما الخيارات المتاحه حقيقه
امام الاتحاد الاوروبي اي انتهاك لقانون
الخدمات الرقميه الاوروبي سيعرض الشركه
المخالفه لعقوبات باهظه تصل قيمتها الى
دفع 6% من حجم العوائد السنويه لها كما ان
تكرار المخالفه قد يؤدي الى حجب المنصه
داخل دول الاتحاد وفي حاله تويتر سيعني
ذلك خساره المنصه لما يقرب من
440 مليون مستخدم معنى من باريس الان
السيد امين حاسبيني وهو الباحث والخبير
التقني في امن المعلومات اهلا بك كيف نفهم
هذا النزاع استاذ امين
مساء الخير
النزاع يبدو انه هو يعني مرتبط بحمايه
يعني نتحدث نحن اولا عن حمايه الراي العام
وحمايه الافراد في في المجتمعات يبدو ان
النزاع كمان هنالك عدد من المؤشرات التي
تقول انه هذا النزاع قد يكون هو مادي نوعا
ما لانه يبدو ان هنالك صراع ما بين من هو
الذي واجبه ان يستثمر في حمايه الافراد
والمجتمعات ويعني
البنيه التحتيه او المعلومات اللي هي قد
تكون مضلله او او غيره
بس كيف ممكن
الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن ان يقول الاتحاد انه
المنصه لن تستطيع التهرب من الالتزاماتها
اذا انسحبت من الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن للاتحاد
ان يضغط
طبعا هنالك العقوبات هنالك طبعا قد تصل
الى حظر تويتر في في منطقه في المنطقه
الاوروبيه لكن على امل ان لا نصل يعني الى
هذا الحد هنالك طبعا القوانين تطبق ان كان
حاليا او ابتداء من القانون الجديد اللي
هو في 25
اغسطس او او يعني
هنالك عدد من التطبيقات بالامكان
استخدامها لمعالجه هذا الموضوع لكن تويتر
منذ سنه تقريبا هن بحاولوا تخفيف المصاريف
فكان هنالك مصاريف كبيره
للتعاون مع عدد من الدول في منطقه
في المنطقه الاوروبيه
لمشاركه المعلومات لاخذ بالمعلومات تحليل
المعلومات ايقاف خدمات ايقاف مثلا بوستات
معينه او او حركات معينه او التحقيقات الى
اخره ابتداء من بدايه الشهر تويتر طلبت من
الباحثين في المعلومات المضلله في الدول
الاوروبيه دفع مبالغ قد تصل قد تصل الى 40
الف دولار تقريبا في شهر
للوصول الى المعلومات لقيام بتحقيقاتهم قد
يكون هنالك يعني نوع من يعني المفاوضات
حول من هو الذي يجب ان يستثمر في الحمايه
الافراد والمجتمع الرسمي حل وسط يمكن ان
تتخيله لمثل هذا النزاع بما يرضي تويتر
والاتحاد الاوروبي كسلطات سياسيه معنيه
بهذا الموضوع بما يبقي تويتر في اوروبا
ويحمي ايضا الشروط الاوروبيه
قد يكون هنالك عدد من الاحتمالات يعني
منها طبعا الوصول الى اتفاق على انه يكون
هنالك استثمارات مشتركه او يعني قد يكون
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني كما كما ظهر
في الاخبار يعني انه هنالك نوع من الاصرار
على ان تكون تويتر مسؤوله عن حمايه الداتا
الموجوده على منصاتها ان تكون مسؤوله عن
الداتا نفسها
ومكوناتها
يعني الموضوع الموضوع معقد لكن على امل ان
لا يصل الى منعه تويتر يعني مثل ما وصل
سابقا الى منع تيك توك يعني
ولكن الى اي مدى سيستطيع الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان يواجه كل مشكله مع اي منصه كانت بهذه
الطريقه ان لم تلتزم بشروط لانه العصر
تغير الوسائل التواصل كاسحه في العالم
اجمع
واما ان يكون الاتحاد الاوروبي خاضعا شيئا
ما لها او ان يعني يغيب عن السمع اذا صح
التعبير مع غياب كل هذه الوسائل عنه
طبعا طبعا يعني ممكن ممكن ان يكون الموضوع
موضوع
قد يصل الى الى الطبقه السياسيه او الى
العلاج السياسي لاحقا يعني لكن حاليا يعني
بذكرني الموضوع هو بامن المعلومات عندما
يكون هنالك مؤسسه ضخمه مثلا مثل بنك مثلا
هو يقرر انه انا
ما بودي انه استثمر في امن المعلومات
حاليا لانه هو عم يفتش على الاروع على
يعني المردود من الاستثمار
فطبعا لما لما بيوصل الى الى النتيجه انه
هو لا يستثمر في الامتثال للقوانين
والامتثال يعني اسس امن المعلومات يصل الى
مكان هو طبعا يكلفه اكثر لانه يتعرض لهجوم
او اختراق من تشفير او غيره ويحصل لديه
خسائر وان كان في في
الزبائن او في الداتا او تسريبات الى اخره
فيعني على امل ان لا يصل تويتر الى هذا
الحد لانه مثل ما ذكرته انتم في التقرير
اوله يعني العقوبات العقوبات الاوروبيه
وكان في امثله سابقه مع جوجل وامازون
وغيره يعني العقوبات الاوروبيه صارمه
وقاسيه تمام تمام شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الشروحات امين حاسبيني الباحث والخبير
التقني في امن المعلومات من باريس تحياتي
اليك
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 اذا كان هناك
من يشعر بالقلق فان الامر بسيط جدا فلينضم
الى دوله الاتحاد بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
وستكون هناك اسلحه نوويه للجميع هذه كانت
كلمات الرئيس بيلاروسيه الكسندر الذي اضاف
احد يمانع في ان تكون لكازاخستان ودول
اخرى نفس العلاقات الوثيقه بموسكو
تصريحاتينكو تاتي بعد ايام من بدء نشر
اسلحه نوويه الروسيه في اراضي بيلاروسيا
حينها رئيس كازاخستان علق على المساله
واشار الى ان مستوى التكامل بين روسيا
وبيلاروسيا مرتفع جدا لدرجه ان الاسلحه
النوويه باتت واحده للبلدين
قد تظنها ساعه الذروه ببدايه يوم عمل او
في نهايته فعاده ما تكون محطات مترو
الانفاق في كييف مكتظه في هذه الاوقات
اناس ينتظرون القطار بهدوء وطمانينه لكن
الحقيقه عكس ذلك هؤلاء هاربون من القصف
ووجدوا في محطه الانفاق ملاذم لهم اكثر من
عام من الحرب مده كانت كفيله لسكان كييف
للاعتياد على اصوات القصف والانذار من
الغارات الجويه التي باتت شبهه يوميه
[موسيقى]
وصوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من ام درمان
للسودان مع اغلاق الطرق تاريخ فبعد ان كان
تعبيرا عن الاحتجاج وجزء من التظاهرات
المطالبه بالحكم المدني بات اليوم وسيله
لابعاد الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع ولتعزيز الامن والدفاع عن المناطق
بعد ان كثرت عمليات النهب والسرقه نتيجه
الفلتان الامني جراء المواجهات
هكذا نختم ملفات واخبار العربيه 360 ولكن
اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع ويتابع فيها صهيب
شراير بعد قليل اهلا بك صهيب وابرز
الملفات التي تناقشها في اخبار الساعه
الليله مساء الخير طاهر نبدا من حيث
انتهيت من السودان سنتوسع اكثر في موضوع
تمديد الهدنه مره اخرى ببساطه سعوديه
وامريكيه كذلك القصف على العاصمه اكياد في
اوكرانيا وكذلك التحديات التي تواجه
الرئيس اردوغان بعد انتخابه لولايه ثالثه
في تركيا نتابعك ايضا الكلمه لكتفر لك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات